leader pal drake interviewing the
replacement dukes of hazard
hey they're going to be some big changes
in the dukes of hazard this fall
well number one enos came back
well that's a weird way to say anus but
okay and the duke boys
went somewhere and we got two new duke
cousins
how about that here they are right they
cute coy duke
this is byron cherry vance duke this is
christopher
mayer hey welcome aboard thank you
it's the new duke boys did you guys
watch the show in the old days
uh i'd say yeah i don't know all right
i don't know that's kind of a tough
night you know yeah because you had
other things planned
i was always working part part to me at
night so i didn't know i missed most of
the shows
but you're going to be watching it a lot
now aren't you uh i hope so
you're going to you're going to watch
you're going to watch yourselves
that's kind of difficult watching
yourself sometimes can be a little
strange but yeah you start critiquing
yourself and
yeah they won't even let us see dailies
as for dailies
you mean once it's shot you can't sit
there and watch it
it's like it's i think it's a thing with
a lot of actors i remember you know a
quote cary grant who we all like to
pattern our lives after but uh
here's the job i mean it's very
difficult to watch yourself and to watch
you know your performance because like
everything else you don't perceive
yourself i bet they ended up doing great
oh
closer no they were replaced with the
original duke boys after the contract
negotiations
i don't think their careers are doing
awesome as others do and stuff it's a
very difficult thing to look at you
could tend to correct or over correct
things that everybody else finds are
quite natural and you know good acting
so
over 2 000 people auditioned for this
particular role and they
they picked you why do you think they
picked you out of over those 2
000 young men handsome young men because
you kind of look like them i mean that's
all they wanted they thought fans
in many cases were right or just stupid
and they just looked alike
so they figured i don't know they kind
of look like a duke boys
[ __ ] it they'll do they'll do my
father's the president of cbs
do either of you drive do you think you
drive cars sure oh yeah no
no we don't we're the two or the two men
in america who don't drive
cars [ __ ] lena what do you do do you
get
do you guys eat food and drink water
do you drive cars
kind of [ __ ] question is that lita
no man handsome young man my father's
the president of cbs
do either of you drive do you think you
drive cars sure oh yeah you think you'll
be driving will you be driving the
general lee
well we do i mean most of the things
they have excellent stunt people on the
show i mean these guys make us look like
uh superheroes you know so uh
i think bar and i will be very satisfied
with kissing the girl and riding off in
the sunset we have no intentions of
flying over fur trees but yeah we do
drive a lot of the stuff ourselves as
far as you know a lot of the action
shots but they you know there's
insurance things everything else so they
don't want you i mean they have men
trained to do all the crazy stuff well
have you shot any scenes yet
oh yeah we started first series we've
got monday
in the first series first one and you're
driving already um
the general lead you know do you know
how much mail
comes into the dukes of hazard every
single week a lot
and you're not allowed to have the
general lee anymore can they even show
the dukes of hazzard's replay because of
the confederate flag
i'm honestly asking i i know it sounds
like a silly question but
are they are is it is dukes of hazards
like off syndication because of the
general lee
like are you not allowed to have a
general lead with a confederate flag on
it anymore
in most play i mean you're allowed to i
mean technically you're allowed to do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you'll have a
car with a [ __ ] swastika on if you
want
but is it frowned upon now
in the south can't imagine every place
in the south gives a flying [ __ ]
sixty thousand pieces of mail
the general lee gets thirty thousand
the general league gets thirty thousand
flash the dogs
i have a feeling that you guys will
probably be getting some mail coming in
pretty soon
oh yeah the one on the left is
definitely on coke
i mean i was picking that up too you can
look at his body language
the guy on the left is on all the coke
watch keep an eye on him
the first series first one and you're
driving already um
the general lead you know do you know
how much mail
comes in watch look at his leg every
single week
60 pieces of mail
the general lee gets thirty thousand
the general league gets thirty thousand
splash the dog
generally is a star we know i have a
feeling that you guys will probably be
getting some mail coming in pretty soon
pretty soon please you're the oldest of
seven kids
what does your family think about all
this no they're real excited because
when i got into this business no they
hate it they hate the fact that you're a
hollywood star now i'm sure can you get
in this kind of business and they go i
mean everybody like
the guys oh yeah this guy died he's
going up for this homie here died at
pretty young at 57 july 23 2011 what did
he die
how did he die
mayor was found dead in the los angeles
home in sherman oaks on july 23 2011.
his death was attributed to natural
causes
at 57. whenever they say natural causes
of 57 it was drugs
right he had three children has three
children
had three children
he appeared on star trek deep space nine
season seven episode 15 in bada bing
bada bang
as a security guard in 1999 his last tv
credit was a guest appearance
on 18 wheels of justice in 2000.
he only played vance duke for one year
he only played
19 episode 19 episodes is what he pulled
off
part no way you know there's too many
handsome guys there's too many of this
too many that the odds are way against
you
but say i've never gone to vegas for the
track of my life so i've got all my luck
saved up for the coming year
last week it paid off yeah and you used
to be a flight attendant
yes ma'am did they bring in male flight
attendants because some of the women
couldn't handle some of the men who kind
of got
out of control was that the reason that
male stewards were introduced on
airplanes
i don't know i think the uh i don't i
guess women just got tired of working
with each other
no it was uh i guess i guess women were
you could make that joke back then
you're not allowed anymore
i had a class of about 20 about 20 25
people and
i'd say each class had about five or ten
but five or six males in there
per class when uh when they hired me
and uh i don't know the exact reason
they did it but but from talking with
some of the other stewardesses
so-called flight attendants they call
them now they uh
oh they just i think they wanted that
you know i think i think way back
way back when they used to be just
stewardesses you know all ladies and
and uh i don't know what brought it
about but they started all sudden man
and started hiring medals and
and i just have to be one of them and
flying bounces if somebody's having
to throw them out at 30 bucks you guys
just did to me
you are so thrilling i just broke my
fingernail off just sitting there
look at the legs no no these are real
look at look at the length this is
[ __ ] great let me read this
i'm sorry you're gonna love this so
in 1978 cherry along with a friend
john snyder auditioned for the part of
bo duke to the upcoming dukes of hazard
schneider ended up winning the part
to which the cherries a guy on the left
to which uh he found much success
a few years later due to a merchandising
conflict schneider and co-star tom
wilpop walked out of the show and sherry
along with christopher mayer
were called in to replace them as coy
and vance duke cherry meyer both made
their debuts in dukes on september 1982
despite fairly similar physical and
behavioral resemblance to the family
leads played by well pup and schneider
cherry and mayor's character coin vance
were not accepted
by the viewing audience and the ratings
for the popular series began to sag
during the 19 episodes in which they
appeared by the middle of 1982 and 83
warner brothers came to a new agreeable
salary with wahpot and schneider
on february 1983 both the original stars
returned to the show cherry and meyer
appeared alongside walpop and schneider
briefly in an episode of bo and luke's
return
and they were written out of the show
never mentioned
again
never mentioned again uh dude on the
left byron cherry was on an episode of
murder
she wrote and in the heat of the night
and vietnam war story
and various tv commercials he also sees
also spokesman for the american cancer
society
you just broke it off you guys are so
excited animals
now you used to play football yes ma'am
so did this one you both play football
okay but the curious thing is you start
to take drama isn't that a little
unusual for a football player to enroll
in drama
which one an actor is an athlete at
heart
yeah i remember reading that francis
ford coppola said that i think it's an
excellent quote because
like we were saying before the
similarities are tremendous well you're
both performers for one thing
love the adolescent adulation of the
crowd yeah you're sucking their dick now
but once the
once you were interviewing the other the
real duke boys
you were [ __ ] [ __ ] on these dudes
[ __ ] lena pal drake's a
i think i love her for it yeah i've
always wanted to get an entertainment
business but
you know it's like back in high school i
always you know it's like everybody's
saying come on come on
you're trying to get me in the theater
you know theatrical part and i was mr
mr jock you know and then i've always
been i used to dive i was a diver up you
know most of my life and i went to
football and
all my brothers were football players
and i said hey i'm gonna be you know i'm
an athlete you know
tom high school was kind of like i don't
know about going to that business but i
wanted it you know i really wanted that
but i didn't want to tell anybody
yeah yeah but after i got a scholar i
was on scholarship you know
through college and i quit my third year
college ball and uh got
uh hillbilly's kind of i used to be
about six two six three until i went to
college and i'm about five eleven
play ball and then i started my growth a
little bit big boys up there so
pounding on year after year but i just
you know i decided to heck with it you
know
this is what i want i'm going this way
and you guys go this way whatever
and i want the entertainment world you
know i want to get in because that's me
well you guys got it
okay yeah hey we're real proud we
welcome you to the dukes of hazzard
thank you
coy duke is byron cherry and vance duke
is christopher may
welcome thank you thank you welcome and
good luck in the show
19 episodes later they were gone
the duke boys work on
not great